and the Washington Post says Murray
Marine Corps leaders promised to change
their culture following a photo sharing
scandal the Marines top general face
very angry senators on Capitol Hill
yesterday and a promise to create new
social media guidelines hundreds of
Marines are accused of posting nude and
other inappropriate pictures of female
Marines online David Martinez at the
Pentagon was more on this story David
good morning good morning about 500
current and former Marines have been
identified as sharing nude photos of
female Marines over the Facebook page
called Marines United that page has been
taken down but investigators have found
at least 17 more sites containing
thousands of photos I felt disgusting I
felt violated Savannah Cunningham has
enlisted in the Marines but not yet
reported to boot camp even so she's
already become a victim of the social
media scandal when a private video she
made was circulated on a marine Facebook
page I had people messaging my current
boyfriend and me saying that they had
seen me on that page and it was pretty
awful Cunningham says the men made crude
comments on photos stolen from her
Instagram account I didn't want to be
like labeled as like a trouble you know
I mean so I just you know kept to myself
and kept quiet about the whole issue
hundreds of current and former Marines
have been identified as using Facebook
and other websites to share nude photos
of female Marines do you agree with me
this is one of the darkest moments and
it needs to be fixed yes senator outrage
senators grilled marine commandant
general robert nellore on Capitol Hill
Tuesday it is a serious problem when we
have members of our military denigrating
female Marines who will give their life
to this country in the way they have
with no response from leadership who is
being held accountable for doing nothing
since 2013 who I'm not gonna sit here
and duck around this thing I'm not I'm
responsible we've got to change and
that's on me not in my Marine Corps
co-founder Aaron Curt Cuomo served from
62 2010 were you aware of these photo
sharing sites when you were in the
Marines we were very much aware of these
sites when I was in the Marine Corps we
brought these sites directly to
leadership Marines are issuing a new and
stronger policy on social media conduct
but Kirk Cuomo doesn't think it will
make much difference we're going to have
another death by PowerPoint for Marines
to have to sit through another annual
training that they're just going to roll
their eyes and be like okay check in the
Box let's let's be done with this and go
about our lives general nellore we'll
meet behind closed doors with Marines at
Camp Lejeune North Carolina today he
will tell them in no uncertain terms
just how unacceptable this photo sharing
is but he will also be trying to
understand this phenomenon of social
media at 64 years of age he is in his
own words generationally challenged Nora
hmm David glad we're following the story
thank you so much